THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING THERE ARE
NO PERSONNEL ANNOUNCEMENTS AT
THIS TIME.
>> Bret: WE WILL FOLLOW IT.
THANK YOU.
MARKETS DID NOT TAKE THE TARIFFS
NEWS WELL.
DOW PLUNGED ALMOST 600 POINTS
BEFORE CLOSING OFF 420.
S&P 500 DOWN 36.
NASDAQ LOST 92.
DEIRDRE BOLTON OF THE
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK JOINS US
FROM NEW YORK TO TELUS MAY BE
WHAT ALL THIS MEANS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
MARKETS CLOSED NEAR THEIR
SESSION LAWS AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE U.S.
WOULD PLACE A 25% TARIFF ON
IMPORTED STEEL, 10% TARIFF ON
IMPORTED ALUMINUM.
ONE STRATEGIST TOLD ME IF YOU
OWN A STEEL MILL GREAT.
IF YOU DON'T, YOU ARE OUT OF
LUCK.
STEEL AND ALUMINUM AMONG THE
ONLY ONES THAT CLOSED HIGHER IN
TODAY'S SESSION.
MANY SEE THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN IS
A STRIKE AGAINST CHINA ANALYSTS
SAY CHINA FLOODS THE WORLD'S
MARKETS WITH CHEAP METALS.
THE TRICK IS WE BUY METALS FROM
ALLIES SUCH AS CANADA AND JAPAN.
CAUTIONING AGAINST CREATING A
BACKLASH.
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN EXCEEDED BY
A FEW PERCENTAGE POINTS THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE LEVELS THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT HAD INCLUDED IN THE
STUDY LAST SPRING.
INCLUDING THE HEAD OF THE MOTOR
EQUIPMENT MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION.
METAL TARIFFS HURT AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS THAT YOU STEEL AND
ALUMINUM WHICH MEANS AMERICANS
ARE GOING TO PAY MORE FOR
EVERYTHING FROM CARS TO BEER
WHICH IS SOLD IN ALUMINUM CANS.
POTENTIAL TRADE WARS ALSO
THREATEN AMERICAN EXPORTERS.
AN AMERICAN FIRM CAN LOSE ACCESS
POINT BLANK TO A FOREIGN MARKET
OR AMERICAN GOODS ARE TAXED SO
HEAVILY IN RETALIATION THAT LOST
MONEY AND LOST JOBS FOLLOW.
AMERICAN FARMERS WITH A LOT TO
LOSE.
THEY SELL TONS OF SOYBEANS TO
CHINA.
AMERICAN DISTILLERIES SELL LOTS
OF BOURBON IN EUROPE.
ANSWERING HIS CRITICS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS IMPLIED THE
BENEFITS OF NEW TRADE LIMITS
WILL OUTWEIGH THE COSTS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID HE WOULD
NOT SIGN THE FORMAL ORDER UNTIL
NEXT WEEK.
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING COMPANIES
AND COUNTRIES CAN PETITION FOR
EXEMPTIONS TO THE NEW POLICIES.